what do you have to do
copy and paste
[Music]
hey what's up my name's samuel leeds one
year ago i went and moved into a guy's
house who was broke he had 23 pounds in
his pocket and i lived with him for a
week and helped him become financially
free it's now one year later and i
wondered how he was doing and i thought
maybe you're interested too so evans
welcome to my house how's it going my
brother thank you so much for having me
i am fantastic yes good so we literally
about a year ago now i came into your
house i spent a week living with you
firstly you know people might be
thinking how the heck did that come
about how did that come about
that came through a process called the
eviction right
which is a very intense process um and
the winner of the eviction got to the
financial freedom challenge you were
feeling very generous he chose free
people i was deferred um and yeah i did
find the freedom challenge and that's
why i'm here today so you came through
the eviction which is like a tv show a
little bit like the apprentice but but
way better than the apprentice for
property uh you won that and and and uh
i went moved into your house spent a
week with you so during that week for
anyone that doesn't know what happened
how the heck did you become financially
free from nothing in that week and then
more importantly i want to talk about
what you've done since then and how
we've been working together and what's
going down so firstly tell me what
happened in that week
that week was i mean it's crazy just
even say me again but literally we could
start from scratch i think for me the
most important thing is that we sat down
we had a bit of a you know um a freedom
formula intensive sort of training right
as into what do you want the week to
look like we had a clear plan um so for
me i was just like it's impossible for
us to do anything because i didn't have
a plan but i sat with you we had a plan
i'm thinking okay that is actually
doable um and went through a step by
step it wasn't an easy process we went
to securing you know renter and deals
packaging and selling them to get the
quick cash flow um you know get my dream
property get a joint venture um yeah it
all just structured it it all happened
because we had a very good structure
right so we had a good plan now there's
a lot of people after that week happened
huge literally in seven days from
scratch and if anyone wants to see the
documentary they can check it out in the
in the link in the description um but
you got a bunch of rental ranks you also
moved house you went from living where
from living in my girlfriend's uh single
bedroom in in a parent's house to living
into my nice dream you know apartment
overseas in london in canary wolf right
yeah you moved into that beautiful
beautiful massive apartment overseeing
canary wharf in london your lifestyle
changed you got a new car and everything
like that and a lot of the comments on
youtube were saying things like you know
rent to rent is risky how long is it
going to be before evans falls again and
there was a lot of skeptics out there
thinking that you had got high fast
results but you were going to fall off
and i said to you at the time my brother
number one i got you and i'm gonna
continue working with you but number two
let's do an interview in a year's time
and we'll see kind of just what's
happened and how you've gone so first
question is did you fall did you have a
time where you where you fell off where
you lost a lot of money did that happen
that didn't happen at all um so
i think a lot of people actually think
you know oh it was risky but for me
i know it wasn't risky and the reason
why i knew he wasn't risky is because
i've seen it before you know i've been
following your youtube channel i've been
seeing so many people from all different
walks of life different ages different
races nationalities being successful
over and over and over again so i know
your system is already proven and if i
can come in plug in play full outs just
literally follow what you tell me i
can't fail because i know the only way i
can feel is if i don't apply myself i
know that's one thing i'm very good at
doing so for me there's no risk um and
yes it's been ups and there's a lot of
challenges but my entire life has been a
challenge i mean just coming to this
country has been a challenge everything
in my life has been a challenge so i'm
very used to challenges so i think for
me the benefit that i had is i failed so
many different times
that i was prepared for failure and
rebuilding and you gave me the proven
step-by-step system just made my life a
lot you know you know made this you know
a lot easier one of the things i say is
if you're gonna work hard anyway you
might as well get rich what do you think
about that absolutely man because the
thing is i've always been a hard worker
i've never been shy i used to work on
the cruise ship i did a contract for
eight months and we worked literally the
day i bought this ship we went
downstairs in the basement i got my
uniform and i didn't stop working until
the day i left the ship so i'm working
every day for eight months so i'm used
to working on however i was only making
about 2 000 us dollars a month and i was
looking every single day so i'm used to
working hard and then i think like wow i
know how to work you know it makes it
wait
i'm not getting rich man my mom's going
to work hard i'm going to get rich i'm
like i'm working i'm working already
every day for eight months i'm still not
rich yeah so i know how to work is
important buy a real handle by itself
it's not going to get you there another
thing is this we spent a week together
and
the the title of the video i think he
might have been some along the lines of
financial freedom in seven days yeah and
at the end of that week you had gotten
to a situation where you had rent to
rent and you had an income coming in
from property that was more than your
living expenses so
you know in that sense you were
technically financially free now
just to be really clear
the real work
probably started after the challenge
right it's not a case of we spend a week
together and then everything systemized
never work again low on a beach what
happened was you were set up for
financial freedom
and you can argue about the terminology
of is it financially free is it not
whatever i mean at the end of the day
look it's it's financial freedom is a
subjective term so talk to me about what
happened after the week was it a lot of
work and are we going to go through the
deals that you've done on stuff because
i know you've achieved a heck of a lot
since then and you are honestly so
successful you just completed on a
property um a couple of days ago a big
brr deal you've got
loads of properties um now that you've
bought that you've been involved in
joint ventures all over the place and
you're making how much how much do you
pay yourself salary so right now i'm
making about 12 to 15 000 pounds a month
right and your salary you pay yourself
at what about 10 thousand pounds a month
okay so every month you're paying
yourself about 10 grand yeah you're
normally making about 12 15 grand um
which we're gonna get on to how you've
done that and what other deals you're
working on but talk to me
during that week it was like um a
whirlwind right we're just doing deals
bang bang bang bang bang raising finance
selling deals putting that money into
rents and rents crazy what happened
after the week finished so what happened
after the week finished i mean you are
right it was a be ever
a wake-up call um not because i relied
on you that week um i mean
what what what happened when you left
the week was i was automatically not in
the environment right um so when i so
when you when you're in an environment
of positivity it's very easy to win
because everything around you is
positive there's no negativity but when
you left i mean like hold on a minute
it's all me
and ellen um so i mean emotionally i was
a little bit you know
i had to get get myself together um so
that was a little bit of a challenge um
but me being the person i am i obviously
was not afraid to ask for help um and
just connected with people you know
other success buddies who's doing the
same and just pretty much i mean yeah
you're doing everything right or you're
doing this wrong just sort of like just
confirm um what you know what i've been
taught in the training so that was my my
my main challenge after the week it's
interesting because the very first
financial freedom challenge i ever did
was with a guy called glenn as you know
and i went to blackpool in two i think
it was 2018. i spent a week with glenn
and glenn became financially free
same as you did obviously not systemized
but he got rental rents and a lease
option and packages sold some deals got
some money and then when i left glenn
got himself into some pickles he um
bought a property from auction which he
hadn't even seen and blew some money
that way um he mismanaged some of his
properties and he ended up getting a
little bit of a pickle and me and glenn
did an interview about this and i had
glenn on my youtube channel and we
talked about what he did and how he
came back out of that and now
of course glenn's doing really well
we're still friends to this day but i
think it's really interesting how
when you are
doing the financial freedom challenge or
when you become successful fast anything
that anything that comes about fast
i think is also easy to lose quickly as
well yes and if you achieve if it takes
you three years to achieve financial
freedom chances are you're going to have
foundations
lessons when you achieve financial
freedom in a week
it is it would be easy to very quickly
undo it and that's why what did i make
you do with the money that you made the
um from deal selling what did i make you
do with every single penny of that money
i mean what you made me do
now i know it's the best thing i've ever
done in my life by the time i think it
was the craziest thing i would ever do
because you may put all that money into
joining the academy right and at the
time i'm thinking like man i've never
made ten thousand pounds ever in a month
let alone a week and i've got put
majority of it into training at the time
i think like i don't really know however
me doing it that way prove to me that i
can do it even when you're not this i'm
like yeah i've got nothing to lose but
as i said earlier my main challenge was
the environment and not being in the
positive environment and again success
buddies to bounce off so at the time i
was a little bit unsure but now is the
best thing
that's literally ever happened it's even
better than a week because the
environment has [ __ ] has completely you
know i got a complete paradigm shift of
the way i think now um and my value so
best thing i ever did so the academy is
a 12-month program and you've just
finished i believe or about to finish uh
your 12 months on the academy so what
have you been doing then um on top of
systemizing what you've got what have
you been doing over the last 12 months
well
when i first started my goal was just to
you know get a bunch of rent arounds and
be making you know 20 30 000 pounds a
month but what quickly happened when i
started making about you know about ten
thousand pounds a month i realized i
don't really want to get in a lot more
of you know a lot more rent to runs a
lot more hassle i just feel like if i
can make 10 grand it's a lot more
more than enough to
cover my expenses and my lifestyle so i
don't really need to but what else think
what i did was obviously i spoke to you
as well was just my strategy to start
you know stop doing the small step but
put a lot more effort on building wealth
so by doing joint ventures and and brrs
and you know pulling over investors in
so right most of my effort have has been
going into that also as well um
something that's always been fulfilling
for me which obviously is helping people
and inspiring people um you know thanks
to you you'll give me an opportunity to
join the team and and really help people
and a lot of things happen i mean i've
i've seen people i've helped them got
started from i can remember from day one
and now they're doing you know crazy
things in properties so for me it really
gives me some of the fulfillment yeah
that was a small part of you know their
success so when you say join the team so
you are now um you come to the events
yeah you speak you give back i don't pay
you to come to the events yep and and
the funny thing is you know quite people
has asked me everyone do you get paid to
be here and you know the crazy thing is
me i look like i'm getting paid but you
know i'm not getting paid i'm not
getting paid financially but i'm getting
paid otherwise in in the sense of me
being there um you know helps people but
i also network with people and you know
do business with them and join ventures
and stuff like that right so you get
paid indirectly not directly yes yeah
okay so basically talk me through this
because this is really interesting so
if you are doing much rents and and and
those types of deals which you consider
small deals now so you go to a you've
got to a point now and of course
everyone knows rent events can be a
little bit up they can be a little bit
down yeah but 10 grand for you is is
like a bad month right so you know that
your business is going to make you 10
grand even on a bad month
instead of
scaling that to 20 and 30 and 40 grand
you've now made the decision to start
doing big deals right so instead of
getting and this is exactly what
happened to me in 2017 when i met lord
sugar and started doing mentoring with
grant cardone grant cardone was like you
want to be doing bigger deals you don't
want to have hundreds of little
residential houses you want and that's
when i got into property development i
started building houses i bought ribs
for the house the castle um and i
started doing bigger deals because i
realized that a big deal and a small
deal had just as much effort 100 so you
got to a point whereby you're making
more than money than you need from
property and from your rent to events
and your small deals and now it's like
actually i don't need more cash flow i
don't need to grow this business what i
need is i need this business to continue
paying me and to give me the time
freedom to focus on big deals but the
question is where are you getting the
money to do big deals
and that's and that's the most that's
the best part of all of this the money
actually comes from
people that i'm around and people that
sees what i'm doing because up until a
few months ago i didn't realize so many
people has got money people i always
used to think were broke they actually
were not broke they were broke to me
because at the time i was broke and they
fought if they tell me they have money
i'll be like a leech and trying to get
the money off them but now they see i'm
somebody of value and i'm doing stuff
you know i'm i'm getting over investors
i'm selling investors dealing holding a
minute rather than have 100 going in the
bank just sitting there again next to
nothing why don't i give everyone a
hundred grand and he is going to give me
10
you know on my money every single month
or why don't i put give him a hundred
government because we can buy a house
together so all my deals right now
literally every single one comes from
you know joint ventures and i mean i've
just i i just come played on one um 170
grand about 40 grand refurb all cash
with an investor's money
so that's for me has been has been the
biggest revelation that
the the thing for me before i commit all
of these years thinking like oh i need
to have selling money money to get the
property i feel like i didn't i don't
even need the money now i just needed
the knowledge to see the things i
couldn't see right so basically
you're not using your money for the
deals that you do now using other
people's money but you're using your
knowledge to get the deals yes
interesting all right let me talk me
through that deal then talk to that deal
yeah and i know i know you've got
multiple deals going on the go and i
know that we've also we're working on uh
we've got a few development deals which
we're doing together yeah and we're
collaborating on which is amazing but
the one that you've just completed on
give me the numbers so the purchase
price is how much it's 170 170 and what
is it so it's currently in a massive
eight bedroom house with loads of you
know kitchens massive space um which i'm
going to convert to a 10 bedroom all
ensuite hmos and also um you know put
i've just put plenty permission through
uh well i've applied for it to change
the basement to a two-bedroom luxury
service accommodation this is not small
stuff yeah she's big stuff bruh it's
crazy in a year yeah you went from i
can't afford a rent to rant yeah that
was what you told me when we first met
you like i can't afford the three
thousand pounds to put down yeah on a
rent to rent and now
you're putting planning permission in to
grow that's incredible so all right 170
the refurbished is gonna cost about 40
000. so that means you're talking about
210 yeah and then what's the gross
development value so it's going to be
about 280 minimum so you make about 70
grand profit yeah from one deal yep
incredible yep so
mindset wise right i want to know
how how one of the things that um i said
somewhat when i wanted to be a
millionaire is i said i don't just want
to be a millionaire for the million
pounds i want to become a millionaire
because of who i'll become and getting
the million pounds
how would you say you today are
different from you a year or so ago how
have you changed through this massive
growth yeah i mean and as i said earlier
on about being the environment the
reason why i said environment for me i
think was the most important thing
because i learned a lot of things for
coming through the trainings but i think
the biggest things i've learned was
indirectly you know seeing how you can
communicate with somebody how you can
come across and how you can sell to
somebody by not trying to get them not
cornering them that they have to make a
decision trying to give them an option
but at the same time it's just like a
lot of psychological stuff right a lot
of you know indirection um but most
importantly my perception of life has
completely changed i mean before i you
know i was trying to just like keep all
my money to myself and you know think i
want to get some more
but
now i give a lot you know now we feed um
we started off with one now we feed five
children um a month in africa and at
first i was thinking like you know may
charity starts at home i'm confident
when i go off in myself first but now
it's crazy that the more i give is the
more i get now my mom gets a lot more
money back home i send you a lot more
but all of a sudden i'm also getting a
lot more more opportunities come more
joint ventures come right um yeah
because because money has to flow
through you yeah you know and that's why
i always say don't be a pond be a
reservoir if you hold on to the i see so
many people that got like five grand in
the bank and they're holding on to it
like oh oh i've got five grand in there
and they stroke it yeah it's like man
you gotta let money flow through you yep
and wealthy people don't hoard their
money wealthy people invest they give
that yeah and the more that you hold a
money with open hands and a generous
heart and give to charity and invest in
yourself and invest in properties and
invest in people the more you invest the
more open-handed you are to receive 100
and you've got to let money flow through
you talk to me a little bit about sales
because when we met
that was your strongest point
you didn't know anything about real
estate or investing you didn't have any
money yeah you had bad credit yeah you
had nothing um no experience but you
would okay sales yeah and
you used to work uh range rover yep and
if everyone got a question about ranger
my range rover i'll call you up yeah how
do i work this yeah you're the man at
range rovers talk about sales
because you mentioned a minute ago about
you don't need to
hard you know pressure corner people to
make a decision um what made you say
that what what what do you say that what
are you what do you bring up sales yeah
because i mean look i was born and
raised in the caribbean the caribbean
you know it's a great holiday place but
opportunities are very slim by the end
of the day every families go eat
everybody's got it so it's either you go
down this straight and narrow or even
you find a way to make it work so for me
in the career because there's so many
opportunities almost every single day
was a hustle it was every single day to
find something you know you know get
some fish done you know by the sea and
sell it i was a natural entrepreneur but
at the time i never knew was
entrepreneurial i was just doing it
because i had to survive but meeting you
i actually understand the psychology of
actually doing it and what i understand
about sales now
and now i'm very happy to do sales um i
said all the time and i understand sales
is about finding somebody who wants what
you have
and just finding a very good medium
right give it to them rather than tell
them look this is my product you need it
no
so everybody doesn't need you know your
product you need to find somebody who
needs it if and if you find somebody
with ninjas it's a good it's a win-win
right because you're probably although
you are a property investor more than
that you're a property entrepreneur yes
right and an entrepreneur is not someone
that just
invests all their money an entrepreneur
is someone that hustles in property yeah
and and and sales is i think one of the
most underrated scales and misunderstood
misunderstood skills yeah people people
think sales as you say is about trying
to you know like a sleazy salesman or a
car you know the double glazing man that
tries to but actually sales as you said
is about having a great product or
service
finding people that need or want your
service and making it easy for them to
exchange and to do business with you you
are constantly having to sell to joint
venture partners you having to sell your
house namely your product to your
customer name of your tenant yeah to
move people in get them to sell yourself
to builders why a builder should come
and work on your project quickly when
they've got other jobs you have to sell
yourself to estate agents while the
estate agent should want to do business
with you and if you can't communicate
yourself
and if you can't explain and articulate
what value you're bringing to the table
yeah why would anyone do business with
you suddenly you can't be a property
entrepreneur and i think you were
naturally quite good at sales you're a
bit of a hustler used to sell fish
that's awesome but now it's like right
how can we translate because i bet i bet
selling
selling a fish
is probably just as difficult as selling
a property yeah one get might get one
you might get paid a pound
one you might get paid ten thousand
pounds exactly or a hundred or seventy
thousand pounds exactly what do you
think about that i feel i think that's
exactly what it is i think learn the
psychology of it it just makes it a lot
easier because i think a lot of people
and they're like hey evan how do you
rent your rounds i've spoken to this
agent i've been into this landlord it
doesn't really work and i'm like what do
you say to them man
sometimes what they say they actually
are right however they find a landlord
an agent who's not open to it they're
close they don't want to do it anyway
and they try to convince them and that's
the difficulty and a lot of people they
do that two or three times and he's like
you know what this thing doesn't really
work however
number one you go say the right things
but number two you have to find people
who's open to it if they're open and if
you're saying the right things then it's
going to be a good fit yeah so i think
it's definitely getting the middle of
definitely getting the right things to
say but also finding somebody who's open
to it yeah if they're open to it then
you can you know but i've seen people on
the training programs where they've like
said you know i just rang this agent and
they said no and you're like
get them on the phone yeah and they're
like
but they just said no and you're like
get them on the phone yeah and you'll
speak to them and you'll get a deal yeah
and it's like
how yeah
and it's not because
the agent wouldn't do rental rents it's
because the agent didn't understand rent
to events or the agent didn't like the
concept of it yeah and you have to ring
them and actually say hey and then you
what would you say in that situation
because i've heard you do it yeah genius
what do you say so if someone says i
don't think we really do rent events
corporate let's you know i'm not
interested what do you say yeah i'm
gonna i'll have a convoy of them go on
let's do it yeah so i'll be like we
don't do corporate let's fantastic no
problem at all i mean there's any
particular reason i mean have you done
it before do you know much about it
um yeah we did it once and we had a
really bad experience and the the guy um
didn't pay rent and we just decided that
we don't want to we don't want to do
that business model anymore right right
so you said it's a little bit too risky
um because you've had bad experiences
before yeah exactly cool fantastic and
is that only because of um company let's
so have you ever had the same situation
with a family before well yeah i guess
we went situation with a family okay so
it's it's it's quite 50 50. well maybe
cool so i mean do you not want to do
business with families as well because
no i don't yeah we do want to do
business with families
all right cool but the main reason why
is just because yeah you haven't um yeah
they've been parents yeah cool well i
mean look in that case you know
what com i mean i'm not sure if you know
the ins and outs of the company unless
but ins and out company letters is that
we're a company and if if we don't pay
you rent if the rules doesn't happen we
don't pay your rent you have the ability
to get us out straight away but if
you've got a family in there they don't
pay you rent you have to go through the
channels you have to you have to issue
them the eviction noise that is a long
process okay with us if if if that's
your main reservation
it's a lot safer isn't it because if we
don't pay you around next month we out
the family you can't really do that yeah
and i'm happy to put in the contract
that we can put you know a guaranteed
rent in there as well if that gives you
a peace of mind um but again how would
that work then how would that work a
guaranteed straight away
i'm not asking you questions right
tell me more exactly and i i think as
well one of the things that's why you're
so successful is
it's not just what you say it's also the
confidence yep and there might be some
agents that say oh get out of here
cheeky get or whatever but you do win
over a lot of agents i've seen it yep i
said it first time so you know how can
you learn that skill
you can definitely get the knowledge
because if you get the knowledge you're
halfway there of course you have to
apply yourself the knowledge is not it's
not just enough but i've got to find my
belly i just really want you know to win
badly so i've got a natural inclination
of just being you know so can you learn
it
i don't think you can learn it i think
you need to have
the willing to do so if look it's the
reality yeah if you don't think you're
going to win and probably you won't but
if you think you're going to win but
there's a lot of great areas so that's
belief now you're talking about
can you learn belief i don't think you
can you didn't believe it's something
that either someone has or doesn't have
100 really because i believe whatever
you believe in you'll do it right if you
don't believe it probably but what about
all the people that come along to say
the crash course yeah they've got very
limited belief yeah but then when they
see what other people are doing their
belief shoots up yeah
that is very true i've actually know
four of it that way but i've seen it
happen because when you
i believe i can change people's beliefs
yes if someone comes to me with limiting
beliefs that is strategy
i can logically
give them the evidence to believe in
themselves and i can
not just logically but i can also
inspire them yeah to just want to be
more achieve more inspire them and give
them the actual facts to say you know
what this is possible if it's been done
but i mean one of the reasons i haven't
got you on the show right now is just
buy people
my job as a trainer the reason i have a
channel is because i started with
nothing no one believed in me
yeah but then when i saw hang on a
minute richard branson
has been successful and he's got
dyslexia too yeah and he's got struggled
academically damn
maybe i could i read his book it
inspired me yeah and i thought well if
he's done it then i can do it too then
when i became successful i put my story
out there inspired other people they
became successful rippling effect and
then i'm then like well hang on a minute
if you've been successful
come on my youtube channel let's inspire
more people and i think one of the
biggest things to get belief is
seeing other people have done it then
your belief goes up when your belief
goes up and you're inspired then you get
the training and the skills
so i'll probably disagree a little bit
and that's what i mean look and i i
completely agree with you but the reason
why i said i i believe you need to
believe is because
you need to be in the environment so
your belief grows up so ultimately you
still need your belief to grow up yeah
however you're not going to see at home
automatically one day and have
automatically have you know magic here's
one thing i do think a lot of people say
to me samuel can you can you make me
financially free like how you made
evan's financially free like how you
made amelia financially free david
echols lawton all these people that i've
gone and i've helped them become
financially free however
if i went and moved into a random
person's house
and said
let's do it
they'd fail
because of what you said belief
and fire
and willingness to want to succeed i
even i can't even give away free houses
man um you saw when i was standing in
hyde park in london saying hey i'm
giving away a house no one believed that
it was legit
and they lost a house
so i think that
you do need belief and you do need to be
willing to do whatever it takes and if
you're willing to do whatever it takes
you've got belief and then you get the
training and the knowledge and you
surround yourself with good people it's
a recipe for success yeah you know big
deals does it ever scare you some of the
sizes i mean we're looking at some
literally seven figure deals right now
yeah does it scare you
at the beginning it was because i didn't
know what was doing and the risk was
high but now i'm actually
um i realized the formulas are very very
similar on a small didn't a big deal
yeah and because i've done a little bit
of the smallers it automatically gives
me a little bit more belief in myself
that i can do it so no it doesn't talk
to me about the freedom former intensive
what's that what what happens oh game
changer for me man that was probably the
biggest eye-opening train i've ever done
with you because that really because a
lot of even even my apartment even
having a range rover that's always been
something i've always wanted to do
however i've always thinking you need to
you need to save about 100 grand to get
a range rover you need to have you know
very good credit and have a lot of money
in the bank to get an apartment but no
because what you've done you've just
broken it down into digestible
pieces of information like wow that's
actually doable so for me
all of a sudden this gray area came
together so it just made sense and when
you believe you can actually do
something you'll obviously do it a lot
more yeah i remember when you said you
wanted to live in a beautiful apartment
overlooking canary warfare how much of
that cost you're like i don't know yeah
well let's find out yeah and you looked
you're like
about three grand a month yeah i was
like okay so what do we need to do to
get that three grand a month um maybe
get a couple rental rents yeah give them
1500 each okay and how long would that
take um a few months nah come on
how's it going
a few weeks let's do it this week yeah
in fact
let's get you in that apartment this
week yeah
we literally found an apartment
that week from scratch yep
and you moved in that week yeah that's
crazy it is crazy but the way that you
teach the thing about it is you just
make everything so
simple man and i'm a simple guy i didn't
do very good at school i didn't go i
didn't finish college then go to uni so
anything that's ah you know it's a bit
too much but the way you just break it
down to a simple format
it's just like i can do that who who
filmed you um do the financial freedom
challenge so the guy who filmed me the
final film challenge was pav okay paul
filmed me and then afterwards he was
like i'm quitting i want to go and be an
entrepreneur yeah pub is no longer here
and then lauren was filmed by amelia yep
even darwin who's filming right now yep
not doing deals not in deals yeah in
fact darwin support house last week yep
congratulations my man darwin well done
know it yeah
just really happy
with big respect but like every that's
what you're talking about environment
emilia was filming the financial freedom
challenge in manchester with lauren and
at the end she was like
i'm booking a week off work man
i go and spend a week with her
you obviously jumped in yeah and now
she's financially free
and then the person who videoed that
darwin and now darwin's doing deals yeah
next thing darwin's videographer
darwin's gonna say hey i just bought a
house and he's gonna hire a videographer
to come out and film him
and in that video like what is going on
the rippling effect what do you think of
uh amelia's financial freedom challenge
i think number one it couldn't happen to
a better person she's an amazing
individual with a very good heart um but
i think when she actually went did it
with lauren she realized that you don't
actually need to be skilled to make
money in property you just need to learn
the basics what's that supposed to look
like no no no
no
and she was like you know
lauren's very successful he's very very
successful and laura is a great guy i
love him the reason why i said that so
much that was her first financial
freedom challenge witness in it yeah
so when she actually saw it first and
she actually wrote on a minute it's not
that technical yeah i think people might
think when they watch the financial
freedom challenge ah
it must be a little bit staged or
but actually
like what you see is exactly
what happens absolutely 100 and darwin's
nodding who's film financial winning
challenges there's so many people we
bring in videographers and and everybody
that's ever been involved in a financial
freedom challenge will testify for that
hundred percent i believe a little man
success leaves clues and if you want to
be successful you can be around people
who's successful because they've they
got to where they got to for a reason
yeah and you know coming to the training
events and seeing people doing it i'm
thinking
this guy is a regular guy you can't even
you know but that's that's the thing
about the environment that's what really
you know
captured my attention so what's your
reason for doing this now like you've
already become financially free now
you're trying to get rich yep want to be
now the goal is to become a millionaire
yeah and we're working on that yes and i
know it's going to happen in the next
couple years yeah i know it's gonna um
why do you want to be a property
millionaire yeah because when i got
started for me the biggest hurdles for
me especially in property was
actually seeing somebody who's got the
same struggles as me get started and
actually be successful because almost
everybody everybody i saw was a little
bit far-fetched you know his mum looked
after him his dad is that whatsoever and
i was this little you know lone wolf
from the caribbean if not much family in
the uk uh had an accent stacking skill
all the obstacles not much money um so i
need for me to actually believe that i
could do i needed to see somebody do it
and they were not that many people right
so i was like you know what one day if i
do it
in fact i actually prayed to god i
prayed to god my god please help me i
need to be successful and i promise you
i'll pay you back and i'll help people
if you let me because i said so i think
because i offered god
you know i'll pay you back if you help
me yeah um so now i'm on a mission but
now i want to help people because i
really know anybody can do it that's
amazing and so many people say to me
they're like samuel if you're making so
much money in property why do you bother
having a youtube channel running
training programs like why do you bother
doing that it doesn't make sense and for
me it's a mission it's some it makes me
fulfilled and you know this yeah it's
about legacy no one's going to remember
me for how much money i made they'll
remember me for how many people i
impacted yeah and i think people only
truly understand that when they become
financially free themselves like you've
done and they go
i get it now you know and and i'm so
glad that you uh have experienced that
and i know you give very generous to
charity uh looking forward to hopefully
bringing you out to uganda yeah
because we've got a lot of good stuff
going on we've got a lot of good stuff
so um big steps for you next what's your
what's the what's your plan to become a
millionaire so i plan to become a
millionaire is again i mean if you look
at
strategy-wise it's obviously a lot to do
on the big stuff do a lot more of the
big stuff because it takes about the
same amount and i know you said that
before but i'm actually witnessing it
yeah do a lot more of the big stuff um
and help a lot more people um fast pound
slow band right fast bounce loop 100
again the fast pan um which i'm doing
now for rental rents and delta and kind
of systemize it give me the enough money
i want um but most of my efforts are on
the big stuff you know brows joint
ventures developments yeah so in a
couple years time we'll see some of your
development buildings it takes time
dickster planning permission and all
that stuff but um in the next couple
years people will see the
apartment blocks that you've built and
houses that you've been involved with
building from scratch and all that kind
of stuff which we're working on right
now yeah which is exciting but what
you've achieved is incredible what would
be your top tip piece of advice to
someone watching this
top tip to somebody wanting
watching this i mean if you really want
this by enough believe me you can but
there's a few things that needs to
happen for you to do it you know you're
just going to magically just have you
know think about why it's going to
happen you need to number one put
yourself in the right environment be in
the right rooms give yourself a chance
you know stop thinking about it again
even if you haven't got money you
haven't got credit whatever obstacle you
have give yourself a chance you know
come down to the free trading meet
people talk to people find a way all
right number one number two you can't do
it by yourself you need you need the
knowledge the knowledge for me is
literally a fresh pair of binoculars i
can just see things i couldn't see
before um so you need the knowledge so
do whatever it takes you to notice
because you really can do it find a way
and get this knowledge because it's eye
opening and number number three the most
important thing is you you go go to work
we can give you all the inspiration we
can give you all the training the only
thing that i can't and somehow can do
for you is do it yourself so you have to
apply yourself yeah but the the applying
yourself comes through the first two
because if you have got the knowledge
and you know what to do you're more
inclined to do it so don't try to do it
by yourself without getting the
knowledge getting the knowledge first so
you will see things differently and
you're more inclined to do it um but you
really can you know i'm literally a
testimonial to get started if nothing so
if you just have an ounce of belief
you know jump on it come down to a free
event um you know just follow exactly
what samuel has taught me and a lot of
people um and apply yourself and it's a
recipe for success amazing love that
couldn't couldn't have said it better
myself get the knowledge
work hard surround yourself with good
people around you well dude massive
respect to what you've done be great
getting to know you as well on a really
personal level yeah and uh working with
you through the academy now you're 12
months on the academy's finished i know
you're becoming an associate now and um
really exciting guys i hope you enjoyed
that video if you did why don't you
smash the like button drop a comment
below as well if you want to see evans
then come on down to one of our training
programs he's often there in the flesh
personally i'm there as well why don't
you come and join us i'll leave a link
in the description and also feel free to
comment on the video if you've got any
questions or thoughts comment below i'll
do my best to answer every single one
and if you want to see more videos like
this every single week i'm helping
somebody become financially free i've
got a whole playlist right here check
out the playlist subscribe and i'll see
you next time peace
you